Kym Johnson and Robert Herjavec are in
love and they don't care who knows it
from patio smooches to Sun lobby loving
the eliminated ballroom duo wasn't shy
about packing on the PDA in Palm Springs
over the weekend our source says their
quote inseparable and madly in love and
that they've been together since the
season first started their fellow
Dancing with the Stars contestant solace
coming all along I think we all kind of
like sensed it from the very very
beginning we were all like maybe I think
that they are incredible like there's
something when they dance together their
chemistry was so exciting I think it was
instant when I found out they were
dancing together I was like first of all
that's the man of her dreams and the
fact that he thought the same about her
I was like I'm just couldn't be happy
for them I think they are two adorable
people I loved having him on the show
together and I miss their presence
around t they may have been eliminated
in the ballroom but their romance gets
all our